you did a lot of singing on the set to  calm your nerves yeah Karen and I you  know we both love music and we ended up  breaking out in song and the in the  makeup trailer you and Karen would sing  together we said what was walked in the  Daily News I'll tell you what's in the  Daily News thorium is autumn and some in  love with a Mississippi girl that he  sacrificed as everything moves all the  way to something we haven't done that  for a year and we didn't practice so  when you see a guy reach for stars in  the sky yeah I bet that he's doing it  for some dog  Oh commitment total commitment hey want  to see Guys and Dolls with the dude in  it don't you know  you